we've already talked about the notion
that a water molecule has polarity to it
one end has a partially negative charge
and the other hand has partially
positive charges and we talked about how
this leads to hydrogen bonds and we
alluded to the fact that hey maybe these
hydrogen bonds give us all sorts of neat
properties of water and what I want to
talk about in this video is one of those
very important properties and that's
water at waters ability to be a solvent
waters ability to be a solvent and this
means that it's easy for certain things
to be dissolved inside of water and
that's super important because that's
how a lot of the chemistry occurs by
things getting dissolved in water and
then interacting and bumping with other
things and this is actually what's
happening inside of cells in the
cytoplasm the cytoplasm which is mostly
water is a solvent which allows a bunch
of interactions to happen between
different types of molecules let's think
about why water is a good solvent and
what types of things it can dissolve
easily and what types of things it might
not be able to dissolve so easily so the
key feature that makes water a good
solvent or at least a good solvent for a
large class of molecules is its is it's
polarity if I were to take some sodium
chloride so often known as table salt so
let me so if I were to take sodium NaCl
sodium chloride sodium chloride the
sodium and chloride are attracted by
ionic bonds the sodium right over here
has a positive charge it has a electron
stripped from it and the chloride has a
let me write that in let me write that
in a different color so the sodium has a
positive charge because it has an
electron stripped from it and the
chloride it is an anion it has a
negative charge it is a negatively
charged ion because it gains an Electra
electron but they are attracted to each
other this has a positive charge this
has a negative charge this is called an
ionic bond but if you put sodium
chloride in water something very
interesting happens this is something
that we've all experienced take some
take some table salt and put it in water
and see what happens it will dissolve
and why does it dissolve well let's
let's just draw it out so this is the
sodium right over here
so that's the sodium it has a positive
charge it has a positive charge and then
this is this is the chloride right over
here it has a negative charge what's
going to happen if you put it inside of
the water let me do that negative charge
in the green what's going to happen when
you put it inside of water well you
could imagine the negative ends of the
water molecules are going to be
attracted to the sodium ion so it's
going to look something like this so you
have the oxygen oxygen oxygen oxygen
oxygen I'm clearly not drawing things to
scale but this will just give you the
idea these all this at this end of the
water molecule all has a partially
negative charge partially negative
charge so it's going to be attracted to
the sahte the positive sodium ion and
then the hydrogen ends the hydrogen ends
are going to have a partial positive
charge and then they're going to be
repelled they are going to be repelled
from the positive sodium ion so it's
going to look something like this it's
going to look something like this and
you're going to have partial positive
charge on the outside partial positive
charge on the outside and now these
hydrogen's over here this will just
interact with water the way that it
would typically with the hydrogen
bonding the molecules just flowing past
each other so the fact that the sodium
the sodium ion here it's an ion it has
charge it is it is able to dissolve in
the water very easily because it is
attracted to the partially negative ends
of the water molecule now similar thing
is going to happen with the chloride ion
and we call a negative ion an anion so
over here over here and actually let me
let me get some let me move it over a
little bit so that I have some space so
the chloride anion let me let me move it
over a little bit so right well maybe
I'll move it over maybe I'll move it
right over here so the chloride the
chloride anion let me see I'm having
with my selection tool alright so there
we go the chloride anion it has a
negative charge so it's going to be it's
going to be attracted to the positive
end of the water molecules so you could
imagine something like this so the
hydrogen ends the hydrogen ends are
going to be attracted to it they have a
partially positive charge they have a
partially positive charge of course you
have the oxygen end that has a partially
negative charge it has a partially
negative charge and I could I could draw
more of these hydrogen hydrogen
attracted there you have the oxygen over
let me do that in the I want to keep my
colors consistent the oxygen right over
there you have the hydrogen once again
this isn't drawn to scale hydrogen it is
bonded to the oxygen and so once again
you can form this I guess you can almost
imagine this this these the shell of
water molecules is going to be attracted
to it it's going to be and it's going to
be attracted for the I guess you could
say the the partially positive end which
is where the hydrogen atoms are is
what's going to be attracted to this
negative ion so this is partial positive
over here and then on the partially
negative side outside of this shell you
can imagine she's going to interact with
the water just the way any water
molecule would and so it's going to be
able to flow very easily so you probably
see something interesting here if
something has charged if it hasn't if
it's an ion or if something has some
polarity it's very easy to dissolve it
inside of water and in this case and
just to have some some terminology here
in this case water is the water is the
solvent so water is the solvent so the
solvent is water and the thing that's
being dissolved in the water we call
that a solute so we call this the solute
so the sodium chloride that those that
is it could view sodium chloride as a
solute or you could say that the sodium
sodium ions are solid and so are the
chloride so are the chloride ions that
is also solid that's also you can
consider to be the solute and so you say
well what kind of things dissolve well
well things that have charged or that
are polar and things that are charged
Poehler and tend to dissolve well in
water there's another thing a word we
use for them we say that they are
hydrophilic so we could say that this
right over here is hydro hydro philic
and if you look at the word roots hydro
is referring to water so hydro is
referring to water and philic means
loving so this literally means water
loving water water loving hydrophilic
and so you might be asking okay
everything we've talked about you know
we've seen water molecules
that's polar we're looking at charged
ions okay we could get that we can get
why they would be hydrophilic they can
incorporate themselves well into the
water but what are examples of things
that would not incorporate themselves
well in the water well in general things
that don't have charge or that aren't
polar aren't going to be able to
dissolve in water all that well and a
good example is hydrocarbons so if you
took some hexane and hexane is a major
constituent of car gasoline so hexane
Hex the the prefix means six carbons so
c1 let me do this in a another color so
if we have one two three four five six
carbons so one two three four five six
carbons and then they're all all the
other bonds are with hydrogen's so let
me draw this as well as I can carbon at
least typically forms four bonds so
hydrogen hydrogen hydrogen hydrogen
hydrogen hydrogen hydrogen this is this
right over here is hexane this thing has
no polarity to it it doesn't form
hydrogen bonds it doesn't have any
polarity and so if you were to take
hexane and throw it into water it's not
going to dissolve that well it's
actually going to kind of beat up and
you would see that if you actually threw
some gasoline inside of water so things
like hexane we would call hydrophobic
hydrophobic so this right over here is
hydro phobic hydrophobic a little reball
up to avoid getting in touch to minimize
its contact with the water because the
water is attracted to itself and it's
not
so attracted to this stuff right over
here and hydrophobic you still have
hydro meaning water and then phobic is
means fearing so this right over here is
water
fearing that's why it's hard to to mix
things like water and oil or gasoline
and water